[Music]
from small land tournaments and niche
player bases to sold-out stadiums and
leagues that may one day rival those of
traditional sports eSports has come a
long way but what are some specific
moments we can point to that help shape
the eSports landscape as we know it
today
to be frank that's hard to trace and
even harder to rank but we here at the
score eSports were up for the challenge
so after weeks of heated debate here in
the office we give you the top ten
definitive moments in sports history
okay guys we know you've probably seen
this play once or twice already but that
doesn't make it any less significant so
as you may have guessed the world-famous
faker Ryu said outplay is kicking off
our list at number 10 by now we
shouldn't have to explain why this
moment is so important to eSports but
for those of you who don't know there
was a point in time when the West wasn't
too familiar with Korean League of
Legends or a young prodigy named faker
in a single moment of mechanical
brilliance and perfect understanding of
the game Baker not only declared to the
world that he is one of the best players
to ever pick up the game but shattered
it's mechanical ceiling the play went
viral in the West and was the moment
when the world truly understood that
South Korea was playing the game on a
different level in its infancy eSports
was primarily observed as part of South
Korean culture but in the year 2000 the
World Cyber Games was formed in an
attempt to emulate a traditional
international sporting event that's why
our number 9 spot celebrates the
formation of WCG and the idea of eSports
as a global competition the fastest
mouse clickers in the country are in
Sydney this weekend hoping to qualify as
Australia's entrance in the World Cyber
Games in October with the goal of
bringing countries together to compete
in multiple titles the event had been
heralded as the Olympics of eSports and
receive sponsorships from the likes of
Samsung Microsoft as well as branches of
the South Korean government in fact in
the early 2000s WCG was considered the
biggest event of the year for many
Western pro players the WCG has grown to
become the world's largest gaming
festival with more than 1 million
participants in a year-round tournament
spanning 67 countries while it wasn't
the only esports event in the world to
feature players from different countries
competing WCG played a huge role in
turning
esports into a competition that
transcends geographical boundaries and
it paved the way for the global
competition we've come to expect today
who would have thought we'd be watching
eSports in major sports stadiums that's
why our number 8 moment takes us back to
a time when the thought of selling out a
sports stadium felt like a dream while
tournaments have been held in famous
exhibition spaces the League of Legends
season 2 World Championship in 2012
marked the first time in which we saw an
eSports event take place in a major
North American sports venue
having sold out in just about a week
10,000 adoring fans were in attendance
all to see who would be crowned season
two world champion and though the Galen
Center may seem small in hindsight
season two will set the bar for future
sports venues to the 2016 League of
Legends World Championship semi-final
broadcasting live from New York's
Madison Square Garden and since then
we've seen a number of historic venues
open their doors for an eSports event
[Music]
with the growth of the League of Legends
eSports scene riot has begun to
transform their competitive leagues to
operate under a franchise model a huge
turning point for modern eSports that
takes our number seven spot and
fundamentally we believe that all
parties that contribute to an ecosystem
should also benefit from it so to do so
we'll be sharing league revenues with
teams and pros beginning in 2018
China's LPL was the first major
competitive region to adopt a franchise
approach in 2017
while the NA LCS followed a year later
which meant security and stability for
the players as well as investors and
team owners but it wasn't just Riot
Blizzard announced plans for a
franchised overwatch league shortly
after the game's initial release
together with our new team owners we are
working towards launching the overwatch
league as the pinnacle of overwatch
esports one that all aspiring players
and audiences can celebrate strive
towards and call their own franchising
and eSports is still in its early stages
and it is too soon to say what effects
it will have in the long run but the
money is there and the promise of
stability has shown that big-time
investors aren't scared to get into the
space and elevate it to Heights that
were once considered a pipe dream
2017 was a turning point for league of
legends competitive landscape by now
you've undoubtedly heard of SKT often
regarded as the greatest league of
legends team in the world but Samsung
Galaxy put an end to their dynasty
besting SKT in a world's grand final
that denied them a third consecutive
world's title
[Applause]
galaxy there 2017
SKT swept world's 2013 finals in
dominant fashion after missing the world
championship in 2014 they would go on to
reach back-to-back MSI finals winning in
2016 they would also take home
consecutive World Championships from
2015 to 2016 cementing their status of
being the undisputed and greatest team
in League of Legends SK Telecom have won
every world championship they have
entered they are our first defending
world champions the entire Korean scene
revolved around this organization who
helped establish a period of dominance
unheard of in any team-based eSport and
players around the world strived to
follow in their trail SKT defined an era
of excellence and although it may have
come to an end their legacy remains the
gold standard in eSports for what it
means to be the greatest and most
dominant team on the planet csgo
may be one of the world's biggest
eSports but it wasn't always that way as
the competitive scene was split between
csgo and CS 1.6 at the time of the
game's release that's why the number 5
moment on our list brings us back to
2015 a year that cemented csgo as the
definitive first-person shooter title
and an eSports juggernaut oh my god I'm
at a loss
these n ayperi cakes they're giving me a
heart attack
this is some of the most crazy
counter-strike I've ever seen how to NID
valve had already shown that they were
willing to get involved and help the
scene grow with the sponsorship of the
major championships ESL one Katowice was
the first major of 2015 and not only was
the competition incredible
the event was record-breaking acrost
which over 850,000 fans tuned in for the
finals a 150% viewership increased since
ESL one cologne 2014 this is what is
about this it's unreal it's we're
grateful to players I've never in my
life been being so happy it's it's
amazing
well league of legends was still at the
top of the eSports landscape csgo had
shot its way up and showed no signs of
slowing down with more records being
shattered at ESL one cologne 2015 I
don't think that's any chance flusher
looking to end this it's going to be I'm
so tired of everything
third major championship and global
Offensive but its growth was not
exclusive to viewership investors were
flocking to the scene as well more teams
were being signed to big professional
organizations and leagues with huge sums
of prize money were announced part owner
of NRG when it comes to counter-strike
an elite I wanted to get deep deep into
the game as csgo was propelled to the
forefront the first-person shooter genre
found its place in the world of modern
eSports taking the number-4 spot is one
of the biggest sports rivalries of all
time flash versus Jay Dom the
professional Starcraft scene in Korea
had long been established since the
earliest days of televised eSports but
by 2007 that pro scene was beginning to
fade the next generation of stars had
stepped up to make a name for themselves
but none managed to achieve the level of
dominance that previous players like
boxer had attained
boxer versus freakin yellow the legends
match to end all legends matches but
with each recurring encounter between
flash and jaedong Starcraft was thrown
into a new age better than any that had
ever come before bringing some of the
biggest crowds eSports had ever seen
flash would achieve an incomprehensible
level of dominance becoming the greatest
player to ever touch a game that was
thought to have been completely solved
at the time and flash has got to be so
stoked Gary goes out taking the golden
mouse grasping it off of its pedestal
thrusting it triumphantly into the air
with multiple championships under his
belt in just about every prestigious
tournament there was his otherworldly
level of play was only rivaled by
jaedong a match between flash and
Jaedong was a clash of gods the two
always took the game to its absolute
limits to a point that has yet to be
seen in any other eSport and redefined
the concept of greatness reshaping the
world's understanding of not only
StarCraft but of competition itself
when we think of dota 2 eSports we think
of the International and when we think
of the International we can't help but
think of its multi-million dollar prize
pools which is why the compendium finds
itself at the number three spot on our
list with a base prize pool of 1.6
million dollars valve had introduced the
compendium for the internationals 3rd
iteration it cost $10 and was available
to be purchased more than once to help
unlock in-game rewards most importantly
25% of the compendiums proceeds went
directly into the prize purse and
through a crowd funded effort ti3
smashed the record for largest esports
prize pool at a single event totaling
two point eight seven million it all
comes down to this one more game two
million dollars on the table winner
first place at the international the
agent and the prestige of being the best
dota 2 team in the world but then can be
International 2014 using the same
compendium system as the previous year
but with added incentives TI fours
crowdfunded prize pool has more than
tripled the previous t eyes with first
place
taking home 5 million dollars let's not
even get started on the most recent TI
prize was increased from 1.6 million 3
million other eSports titles and game
developers with follow in Valve's
footsteps riot for example crowd funded
their 2016 worlds prize pool by selling
in-game cosmetics bringing the prize up
to a total of five point zero 7 million
dollars which ended up more than
doubling the base amount of 2 point 1 3
million Blizzard's introduction of the
war chest for starcraft 2 in 2017 added
an additional $200,000 to the base prize
pool of 500,000 fans have shown that
they're eager to help contribute to
prize pools in exchange for in-game
rewards proving the model to
a success for eSports Evo moment 37 a
moment so incredible that it transcends
the world of fighting games this
timeless classic takes the runner-up
spot on our list and deservedly so in
2004 there was no twitch there were no
million-dollar prize pools and for most
people competing in video games was
merely a hobby the hundreds of attendees
were all there for the love of the games
and there is no moment in eSports that
rivals the level of pure passion seen in
moment 37 you know everyone kept talking
about how great he is and everything
like that but the Daigo Perry was that
one moment where it happened and it
happened in front of a bunch of people
and it was ridiculous low-mid 37 had it
all two players of different
nationalities battling their hearts out
for a chance at glory the home crowd
favorite against a foreign legend locked
in an intense psychological war and in
the blink of an eye a never-before-seen
display of unquestionable mechanical
prowess led to one of the greatest
comebacks ever released captured under
the deafening roar of a crowd who had
just seen the impossible made until the
air
even those who don't understand Street
Fighter can appreciate its brilliance
the clip had gone viral in a time when
that was no easy feat and remains one of
the most watch eSports moments of all
time moment 37 is everything that
eSports should be and to this day
continues to embody the spirit of
competitive gaming
[Applause]
what started as a guy broadcasting his
life in 2007 turned into the most
revolutionary esports moment of all time
which is why we're crowning the birth of
twitch TV as our number one moment we
spent about six months working on
justin.tv gaming and getting quite good
results before realizing needed a new
brand and we relaunched
that brand as twitch in 2011 in 2011
justin.tv had launched their dedicated
streaming platform for gamers twitch TV
while justin.tv was not the first and
only platform available for streaming
video games the decision to split off
from the main site and rebrand coincided
with the global boom of esports that was
happening at the time Starcraft 2 had
just come out and that was pretty
popular and people were like uploading
videos to YouTube it was like we should
like try to get more than this content
on the site right and there's no doubt
that twitch helped eSports grow even
bigger with its accessibility while
companies like MLG had been broadcasting
tournaments on their own platform for
years before twitch the name had become
so closely associated with eSports that
fans would not settle for anything else
if there was a tournament taking place
chances are you would watch it on Twitch
and if there wasn't then you could just
be watching your favourite pros at home
oh really just about anyone playing
anything you could think of now you are
camping no I'm look at your camping in
the bookstore moving who told you to use
this part probably which had become an
outlet not just for eSports but for pros
and entertainers alike to share their
gameplay grow their fan bases and grow
the industry eSports was being broadcast
around the world 24/7 for four
in 2014 Amazon announced that it had
acquired twitch TV for nearly eight
billion dollars and since then live
streaming and eSports have only gotten
bigger music on theirs misquoted hotter
and streaming video yeah I think that's
the case and I really think that the
including everything including
everything
simply put twitch has cemented itself as
not only a Titan of live streaming but
exemplifies the ideal eSports viewer
experience and who knows where the
industry would be without it well guys
that's our list and let me tell you this
was one of the hardest we've ever put
together if we missed your personal
favorite moment in eSports history let
us know in the comments and make your
argument and I'll see you next week
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button